[Music]
what on earth is going on one minute i
was just doing my job protecting the
president of the united states from any
potential attacks next thing i knew
thousands of people were dead the world
was thrown into chaos and the so-called
scp foundation had declared war on the
human race okay okay let's get back to
day one before things get too confusing
day one i'm a member of the president's
secret service so it's my job to keep
potus safe from all manners of potential
dangers my son thomas was in the care of
my ex-wife across the state when
everything went south it started on the
white house lawn where the president was
giving a speech about his plans to
shrink the deficit that's when he
appeared a stranger slipped into the
press junket he was dressed like a
british butler it was almost comical
myself and the other agents immediately
flagged him as a potential threat and
moved in to intercept him that's when
things went nuts this butler was one of
the greatest fighters i've ever seen he
effortlessly disarmed the intercepting
agents and while we desperately tried to
wrestle the president off the stage the
butler stole one of my fellow agents
pistols and blew off the president's
head with one perfectly aimed shot of
course we returned fire mowing the
butler down in the hail of bullets it
was already too late people were
screaming and running i could see out in
the city beyond there were explosions
smoke rising a cacophony of screams in
an instant everything had changed we
hunkered down in the white house to
protect the vice president that's when
upon turning on the news we saw the
message had been sent to every company
every station and it read the following
is a message composed via consensus of
the o5 council for those who are not
currently aware of our existence we
represent the organization known as the
scp foundation our previous mission
centered around the containment and
study of anomalous objects entities and
other assorted phenomena this mission
was the focus of our organization for
more than 100 years due to circumstances
outside of our control this directive
has now changed our new mission will be
the extermination of the human race
there will be no further communication
day two of course i try to get through
to my ex-wife and check that she and
thomas were okay but by that time
communication had already broken down
strangely the internet and major tv news
channels remained in operation allowing
them to spew a constant barrage of the
horrors going on outside all over the
world hideous monsters and malicious
creatures had flooded the streets
killing human beings on mass i don't
understand is the scp foundation behind
all of this i hadn't even heard of them
until yesterday and now they were
apparently releasing living nightmares
everywhere apparently with the intent of
wiping out the human race all i could do
was stay in place hope my family was
staying safe and do what i can to
protect the vice president day three the
vice president is dead the same could be
said for the rest of my team some
terrifying zombie-like man somehow
breached our security perimeter and
melted down the president and six secret
service agents into this thick black
sludge obviously not an ideal situation
at that point the chain of command
collapsed entirely we decided to make a
run for it bullets didn't seem to work
on that rotting old freak and i'm not
the kind of idiot who sees the point in
expending a few extra magazines on a
lost cause but by the time i was outside
it was already nightfall and the horrors
were just beginning day four it's hell
on earth out here i was wandering the
streets of dc trying my best to remain
scarce despite the chaos unfolding all
around me there were these
creatures abominations of human flesh
twisted into unimaginably unnatural
configurations roaming around attacking
any humans they saw and anyone they
touched started to transform into more
of them i decided to sleep in the back
room of a ransacked post office that
night i didn't want to move in the dark
with these things around one touch and
i'd be dead
no thank you
day five why the hell did they do this
to us these monsters at the scp
foundation flooding the world with
abominations intent on ending human life
one of those monsters almost killed me
today i was trying to sneak down a back
alley when i heard the chittering of
bony legs following me i turned and saw
it reaching out towards me with fleshy
tendrils i raised my handgun and fired
several times to no effect i was
preparing for death or worse when some
huge metal vehicle i couldn't recognize
pulled into the alley men spilled out of
it while they weren't just men they were
cyborgs in heavy technologically
advanced armor and weapons straight out
of star wars they burned the creature to
death with a volley of concentrated heat
beams i thanked my rescuers profusely
and asked them their names they simply
told me we are devotees of the broken
god stay safe out there fellow traveler
mccain be with you day six i wasn't just
surviving for my own sake you need to
understand that i wanted to get back to
my ex-wife and son as quickly as
possible knowing all the horrors that
the scp foundation had unleashed onto
the world for no logical reason as
morbid as it sounds even if we all died
and rather we die together than apart
but every day i developed a new reason
to know this journey wouldn't be easy
while trying to escape from one of dc's
more densely packed urban areas i
encountered a horrific monster it looked
like a giant mutant crocodile the size
of a bus vicious as hell and it could
talk when it clasped its eyes on me it
growled disgusting
it started running towards me but the
actual physical structure of dc saved my
ass this time you see the streets of dc
are designed to give in and collapse if
ever huge military vehicles roll over
them in order to prevent the capital
from being invaded by a military force
the reptile clearly didn't know this
because it seemed awful confused when
the ground gave out underneath it and i
was able to run to safety while i tried
to scramble up the walls day seven a
week into this hellish new world and
against all odds i'm still alive though
it's not for lack of trying from the
gaggle of killer freaks the monsters at
the scp foundation have unleashed to
terrorize the streets today i saw
something terrifying a man was lured
into a dark corner by the voice of a
young child claiming to be his daughter
he approached the dark with tears in his
eyes when a pack of monsters jumped out
and began devouring him alive their long
sharp fangs and raw red hides are going
to linger in my dreams forever you can't
trust voices anymore you just can't
trust them day eight i'm almost at the
edge of the city but the nightmares
continue i was able to narrowly dodge a
group of men walking in perfect step
like one of those flash mobs that used
to always pop up in the middle of them
there was a woman with what looked like
some kind of strange skin condition they
didn't seem all that aggressive until
they came upon a pair of women also
trying to make their way out of the city
the men in the trance like stayed
charged at them holding the woman in
place and seeming to strangle them while
the woman with the skin condition just
laughed i would have charged in there to
help but there were maybe 20 of the
hypnotized men in the group and with one
magazine of handgun ammo left even with
perfect aim i couldn't drop them all but
the guilt of leaving those women to die
will stay with me forever over the next
nine days i encountered zombies i kid
you not genuine honest to god zombies
the walking goddamn dead confessing a
road on the edge of town there was a
huge crowd of them gurgling and growling
skin looking green and rotten i've seen
so many zombie movies but seeing the
genuine article in person was still
utterly revolting when they spotted me
and started running towards me i
instinctively pulled out my weapon and
fired several times i scored a couple of
respectable head shots but they just
kept coming the only thing i could do
was run into a nearby gas station and
lock the door behind me for a second
there i thought i was doomed until i
suddenly developed the wherewithal to
check behind the cash register where to
my immense luck the clerk had apparently
left a pump action shotgun with several
shells with the extra firepower i snuck
out of the back of the gas station
approached the zombie horde from behind
and executed them with a series of well
chosen shots i managed to steal and
refuel a car to get out of town on the
way out just to add to the surreality of
the whole situation i saw a witch in a
ditch sounds like i just made it up for
the rhyme but no there was a genuine
witch hiding in the grass chewing on a
dead body that was the moment that i
knew on some level that things would
never be normal again the best i could
hope for was survival the 21 days after
that were incredibly eventful to say the
least thank god i had forged a shotgun
with me or i would have been a goner
because almost as soon as i left town
that huge monstrous lizard appeared
again carrying a dead deer in its mouth
had it followed me or was it just a
coincidence that i ran into it again
well maybe there was more than one of
those horrible dinosaurs out there but
the second didn't notice me driving by
it immediately began to chase me i put
the pedal to the metal and hoped to be
on hope that this monster wouldn't catch
up to me but i kept seeing it get bigger
and bigger and my rear view mirror that
creature was impossibly fast for its
size and believe me when i saw it was
getting close i started sweating with a
sharp turn at a crucial moment i was
able to gain a vital lead and lose the
beast
soon enough it was no longer in my
peripherals which was exactly how i
liked it then i ran into a gaggle of
horrific creatures that i can
well hardly even explain i was getting
out of my stolen car to forage for food
in a nearby supermarket when suddenly i
was swarmed by what i can only describe
as a group of
human chicken monsters as stupid as they
sound compared to the other things i've
faced they were fast and incredibly
aggressive i was lucky to dodge a few of
their brutal charges and retaliate with
a few blasts from the shotgun which at
least bought me time to escape even
though i had to abandon my car easy come
easy go seem to be the rules of this
terrible new world are they ever going
to run out of horrible beasts to throw
at me well let's see over the 11 days
that followed between periods of pure
hiding i actually had a first-hand
confrontation with agents of the scp
foundation after all the things i've
seen if i could punch every single one
of them so hard that they'd never wake
up i do it in a heartbeat it was their
fault that all this was happening and we
never even get to know why well that's
not entirely true i was able to get
myself some answers the hard way i saw a
helicopter circling above while i was
hiding behind a small collection of
buildings they were shining a spotlight
around and anytime they saw a person
walking out into the open they
ruthlessly gunned them down when one
person managed to duck away and run
through a narrow alley the helicopter
landed and several men in tactical gear
with assault rifles stepped out when i
recognized the scp foundation logo on
the side of the chopper i felt my blood
rising to boil these were the ones who
killed all these people as they began to
disperse i approached them from behind
with murder in my eyes and used the
shotgun to kill several of them before
any of them had a chance to retaliate i
grabbed one of their fallen assault
rifles and fired back killing or
injuring them all the ones that were
heavily injured were incapacitated but
oddly they didn't seem to be in pain i
aimed the gun at one of their heads and
told them to tell me why they were doing
this that scp foundation foot soldier
just smiled and said
you're never gonna know how much we've
helped you but that's okay we're used to
dying in the dark you'll have to learn
so of course i shot him in the head hey
wouldn't you i was better armed than
ever soon enough i had a new sidearm and
an assault rifle along with a hell of a
lot of ammo from the fallen scp
foundation agents i took a little joy in
the irony that the scp foundation the
ones behind all of this had provided me
with the tools to defy their reign of
terror but none of that prepared me for
that maniac to attack after getting a
few days rest in a basement apartment i
broke into i emerged to continue the
journey i was maybe about 50 miles away
from where my ex and son were living if
they managed to somehow stay put and
survive all this time but when i left
the basement apartment something was
waiting for me it was a man wearing a
white comedy mask dripping with this
strange black gunk and carrying a fire
axe well hello there good sir he said
with a laugh how lovely to meet you it's
been a while since i've seen another one
like you
you look like you're carrying a lot of
weight on your shoulders but don't worry
i can help with that
[Laughter]
he gave a diabolical laugh and swung the
axe at my head i was able to narrowly
dodge the blow and return fire into
center mass with my rifle he seemed
unfazed he just laughed and started
charging forwards with another swing
from the axe rather than shooting him
again potentially attracting some
unwanted attention i decided to just run
for it every day there are new surprises
out here i made my way through a small
town that had been utterly decimated
homes and buildings were empty a huge
stack of human corpses sat in the center
of town on top of the pile there stood a
heavily tattooed man carrying a huge
black blade in each hand he was clashing
the blades together and calling out this
world has no worthy opponents for the
mighty abel step forward and meet my
blade so at least you can die with honor
you sad timid little sheep i didn't feel
like dying with honor that day so i
instead chose to discreetly make my way
across the town hoping that the mighty
abel wouldn't notice me and this paid
off in the end as i was able to find an
abandoned motorcycle and hightail it out
of there with all my scavenged weaponry
at long last i was so damn close just
before day 90 that monstrous reptile
came back i swear to god that monster is
following me it's more than just a
coincidence now i was no more than 20
miles from my ex's place driving at
great speeds on my new purloined
motorcycle when that giant scaly monster
emerged from the side of the road and
knocked me off my bike if i didn't think
quickly and rely on my training i would
have been killed i'd done two tours with
the marine corps in afghanistan before
being selected to defend the president a
job that technically i'd failed
miserably at but those skills might be
the only thing that could let me stand a
chance against this monster it reared up
and tried to attack me again i used my
stolen assault rifle to concentrate fire
on its eyes trying to at least distract
it its wounds healed quickly and the
pain of the blasts doesn't seem to have
affected it in the slightest but every
time it lunges for me i'm lucky enough
to have the room to dodge it
this isn't sustainable i know that it
will have energy long after i tire what
i need is a distraction so i can get the
hell out of there then an idea hits me i
turn the gun on the motorcycle's fuel
tank and fire off a few rounds
boom
a nice big distracting fireball it buys
me a few seconds but that's enough to
let me get away down a narrow alley and
make myself disappear all i can say is i
really hope i don't see that monster
again isn't three times enough for one
life but just when you think things
can't get any stranger you see something
that almost breaks your brain with its
sheer surrealness while traveling
through the town next to the one where
my ex and son live i saw a heart like a
giant beating heart on spider legs with
a scorpion tail destroying everything it
was tearing buildings apart and somehow
setting people on fire with its caustic
venom what on earth was the scp
foundation that it even knew about all
these things i just kept walking
avoiding attention it's all i could do
it's all anyone can do no one is saving
a world like this they're just avoiding
getting killed in it or helping someone
they love to avoid getting killed
speaking of only one day off now only
one day off day 100 i arrived after all
this hell after seeing all this
nightmarish carnage that i'll never be
able to unsee i've reached the home of
the ones i love the ones i've been
surviving for i walk up to the front
door step inside and find that the house
is empty not a soul in sight for a
moment i'm terrified had they been
killed there was no blood no bodies no
sign of anything out of the ordinary it
means that like myself maybe they were
on the move maybe they were fleeing to
find safety of their own and if that was
the case i had a pretty good feeling
that i'd know exactly where they are but
my thoughts were interrupted by a loud
rumbling noise coming from the house's
basement now go and check out scp-5000y
the full story compilation and how
scp-682 tried to stop scp-5000 for more
from this horrifyingly apocalyptic
scenario